please be with you welcome to the Dean
show do you know that we're going on
close to ten years strong at hamdulillah
and that we're around our 500th episode
of the D show and I think everybody
who's been supporting and tuning in with
no breaks
we've been continuous at hamdulillah
continue to support the program and with
no exception today we have an exciting
program we're gonna be talking about
dating in Islam dating yeah did you know
that the halal dating way that you set a
date and you meet the madam and you tie
the knot but what's stopping people from
tying the knot in today's day and age
used to be a time it was quite simple
nakai very easy process very quick - but
there's big dilemma now somebody is here
in the studio that is on the ground at
the meet and greets a coordinator who
was going to be giving us the insight
his insight here in addition when we
come back so we can benefit and
hopefully we can solve some of these
dilemmas that were having and people who
end up tying a knot in a halal way we'll
see you in a second don't go anywhere
right back
this is the how are you doing brother
Jay I'm doing wonderful now people are
out there who go to the l- seminars
that's the guy in the front row is that
you sometimes so you you attend
frequently all of the market of seminars
yeah I'm working towards getting a
bachelor's degree in Shaolin in the next
year you're an ass give them you want to
give up marketable plug yes market if
some people are what is this old moto
busines Institute that gives you a basic
knowledge on Islam and a very
interactive fun educational manner and
I've been involved for less actively
involved for last two years traveling
all over the country you got to shake
good shake coming in and shake will
leave a Sunni he's got the thick of
fasting that's coming up now isn't it
yes in three days it only three days
Friday hopefully this would be out
before then people can benefit now
people like okay I mentioned tying the
knot I mentioned the halal dating set a
date meet the Muharram meeting greet
you're a part of your Chicago
coordinator we see at the events where
they have the half our Deen with Bob Ali
you know Baba yes I know Bob Ali I work
with the people that they had that come
in so I'm the Chicago contact force a
half hour Deena I've been helping out
for the last three years so whenever
they have an on-site event typically
once or twice a year I help you know
with anything they need advertising
marketing anything for the Chicago
location now what is half-hardy what is
this because we know how far Dena's to
complete the faith what does this
organization trying to do so how far
Deen has two components two main
components to it I'm not the expert or
the one running the show I'm supporting
the Chicago contact but but basically
they have two things they have two on
site matrimony
site where people pay monthly to post
their profile and then if anyone is
interested in them they will communicate
online and it's protected and private
and bubbly has created that and based on
what he's seen in the past he's tried to
make it excellent and perfect the
matrimonial scene and then they have the
second component which I'm a part of
when it comes to Chicago which is the on
site where we have people meeting and
greeting from all over the country
sometimes the world they come into
Chicago and we try to have you know
equal number of men an equal number a
woman let's just say 60 60 and and then
we do interactive questioning you know
deal-breaker questions and making a
little bit game interactive and you know
something more than than what they do
which state a lot of matrimonials do
which is a major mistake which is called
speed dating so we don't do that it's
more you know they talk they get to know
each other in a halal environment and
then and then men will move from table
to table so that they're able to meet as
many opposite potential matches as
possible so so tell us now what is going
we know that okay many people they want
to get married and the main one of the
wisdoms behind marriage is to protect
society but to protect yourself because
it's natural to be attracted to the
opposite gender and to come together in
a way that's acceptable by the Creator
because we know all of those the
ramifications when people go out and
they become promiscuous and the morality
takes over and the society gets
destroyed so this organization and and
and yourself you're trying to help
facilitate men and women coming together
in the in the pure way in marriage so
how is how do you see now being on the
ground when people come to these meet
and greets what's the success rate I
don't have the exact success rate but I
know that there's been the last few
events that's helped out there's been a
few people that were able to get engaged
I think there's one or two that were
able to get married which is not bad for
a small meet and greet sessions that
they've had
but the issue I'm seeing a lot of times
that people are not preparing for
marriage they're jumping into it without
getting the proper knowledge and
resources to be able to find somebody
and then staying married okay well
there's something we gotta take a break
but we really want to get into some we
want to keep it real and get into some
things that you've seen that are
hindering people from getting married
one of them is pursuit of education and
the woman or man they end up getting
past their prime and then that's it you
missed a boat and then there's all sorts
of other things along with this that
we're going to be covering that we can
hopefully dissect and give some
practical solutions here with brother
Jay on the Dean shell don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the video follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
welcome back to the Dean show and you
mentioned one thing not being prepared
just jumping in blindly right yes you
don't how come why do you think of most
of the time when we take some seriously
via be a job you prepare for a test you
prepare for it but you say you're saying
that what you're seeing that most people
aren't preparing themselves for this
great endeavor yeah it kind of confuses
me a little bit because yeah exactly
what you said when somebody wants a job
they'll do everything and get the
education and they'll prepare for
interviews and don't ask people on
LinkedIn or whatever a you know helped
me get a job so what I'm seeing a lot of
times is when people want to get married
they're getting married for a sake of
getting married because everyone's
telling August I'm to get married when
they do choose to get married they're
just doing it and there's not
preparation and I think that's part of
the responsibility that we have but I
think the other component is our leaders
in the muscle community they're not
they're starting to create the resources
now in the seminars but still there's a
big lack that they're not creating pre
marriage workshops counseling sessions
and so forth that there's a more of a
reaction that when people do get
divorced the leaders will get a little
bit more involved
but prior to that like being more
pre-emptive there's not enough support
there and people are not reaching out
and pushing for the demand so our
leaders can step up and meet that demand
so it's not like just jump out of a
plane and I'll figure it out or get to
the airport and then you don't have your
visa stamp you're not going I mean I'll
figure it out when I get there
exactly there's no planning and it's
just like okay you know if I get married
all my problems I'm gonna be resolved
and that's just not realistic or you
pick up a lot of bad habits from your
parents possibly maybe dad treated wrong
mom right mom was terrorizing dad or dad
was terrorizing moms that bad a flock
bad character and now you just pick up
those traits and think you got it but
now you got to fix those up according to
the Dean exactly I mean my specialty is
emotional intelligence and
self-development and and using those
skills that I've gained over the last 15
years I've realized that people they are
taking their mom and the marriage are
our parents I mean let's just say I love
my mom and dad and and they're you know
there's no one else that I'd want to be
on mom and dad but the fact of the
matter is many of our mount mom and dads
are first-generation immigrants from
different countries and they may not
always have the education and the wisdom
to to teach us how to get married in
this country you know so it's a brand
new experience for us and em and they're
just trying to survive being in this
country not giving us the skills that we
need beyond our food water and shelter
yeah no doubt probably most people pick
up some good things there's a lot of bad
baggage now that we need to go ahead and
test with the Dean if it's and that
requires continuous education exactly
like anything we do tell us now another
thing is brothers getting you mentioned
a lot of brother is getting cold feet
running away from marriage and women
what did you mean missing their prime
yes so for men what I've experienced is
many men are there if men choose to get
married you know they go for it and
that's the minority but the majority of
men what they're doing is they're scared
of commitment or there's a sting where
if there's somebody that's interested in
them or they're being pushed to a you
know this girl may be good for you they
have this mentality where the grass is
greener and the other side that there's
something better out so don't wait or
they're fearing
because you know they're not making
enough money Devon
going to college or if they do go to
college you haven't finished scholars or
they don't have a business or some sort
of skill to make enough money there's a
lot of pressure on them to financially
provide so there's that fear of
financial stability the lack of it and
then there's a fear that if I choose
this person what if what if I want
somebody else what if somebody else is
better for me five years down the line
so there's that fear of committing to
somebody and potentially being trapped
or cornered and like aw I can't suck it
they second-guess themselves so there's
this emotional immaturity with a lot of
men that a lot of women are complaining
about that I see is one of the top
reasons why men are not getting married
or committing to getting married
so you see men are scared of commitment
they're scared of commitment and and and
there are and it's it's like one of
those biggest secrets that they have all
day that they're not sharing don't use
any excuse or say anything but really
it's a fear of commitment I mean it's
easy just to and women need to be not
naive to this that men will just go
ahead and use a woman right tell her
those sweet nothings and they don't have
to commit there give her everything she
wants as far as what she wants to hear
but at the end of the day using abused
and then she's out like yesterday's
newspaper exactly the essence of
marriage it's a protection for men and
woman but what I've learned that in our
Deen talks about this marriage protects
the woman and and if the woman you know
that's what gets pregnant you know part
of marriage it protects her kids and it
protects her if they're married if
they're not married then there's not
really that responsibility that the man
has for his you know let's say which is
harm girlfriend or or hit you know the
baby out of wedlock which is happening a
lot now there's happening a lot and I
even in our community yeah and that's
the worst thing a woman can do now not
to say it's the end of the world
I mean God Almighty Allah is the most
merciful forgiving but one of the worst
things either can do men or women is to
go ahead and give this special thing up
before marriage
exactly and you have a lot of predators
out there you know and women are just so
fragile that fragile vessel so marriage
it's it's really beautiful it's safe
scars that woman is chastity the man
chastity or but really the the woman
yeah
you know from from falling into
something and at the end of the day now
it becomes even even harder and you see
a lot of women now because it's sad to
say most of times men will look at it as
a stud you know Biff he's not in Islam
but just in the culture if he's dating
multiple women he's the Hugh Hefner
but women now it's even changing women I
try to imitate men and be like you know
the man and they'll just hop around from
from different partners yeah I think on
a woman and you know and I tend to be a
little bit more a little bit more
merciful and a woman in more than
immense and because of what I've seen
but what's happening on a woman has
coupled indigo number one they're
delaying their marriage because they
want to finish school or they're getting
a lot of pressure from their parents
saying look you need to finish school be
a nurse but get doctor whatever the case
is finish school get a career and then
get married almost as if it's an
insurance policy of you know just in
case which I think I understand where
they're coming from but I think it's
creating a problem because then it
pushes a lot of women to get married in
their early 30s mid 30s late 20s which
is not necessarily bad but if you want
to have kids and get it within a certain
time frame there's a time limit to
having kids you know and there's more
complications as you get older so number
one woman are delaying marriage because
of the fear of divorce or the pressure
of society and parents to finish school
and get a career and the second thing
that there that a lot of women are doing
is they're being unrealistic and they're
having very high expectations on men and
they're having these unrealistic
expectations that less than one percent
of men can fulfill so it puts them in a
situation where they delay their
marriage much longer than they need to
it's a pound of law it's upon a law so
much to talk about we're gonna get back
with some story some real stories but
and we're gonna go elaborate on what's
this prime thing you know with women
that we're hearing again all in the
essence of benefiting so we can go ahead
and change and alter some of the things
that we're doing so we can have a better
result tomorrow more with brother jay
hannity show don't go anywhere we'll be
right back please subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
back here on the Dean show when I opened
up I talked about dating people like
what dating in Islam
yeah set up a date to meet the maja do
everything the right way but no we got
true stories you know brothers I'm
talking to her brother and he says look
he's been dating this girl for years he
loves her I said man when she just marry
her right he said my mom will kill me
because she's not yet Muslim and talk to
her about the Dean right enrich her with
the purpose of life and from here I mean
you could be getting paid for a meeting
with Baraka meaning with the blessings
but you're doing it in the Haram way not
the halal way and then I mentioned to
him I said look you're not questioning
your mom's gonna kill you I guess
because she's not from the same region
made Palestine or whatever the case are
she's not from the same town tribe so I
said look you you wouldn't ask your mom
when you want to go do something Haram
when you want to do something that's
displeasing to the crater you don't get
her permission but white people they go
ahead and now they need their permission
to do something halau doesn't make sense
yeah it doesn't
what would you come and say I mean the
thing is what I've seen is there's kind
of just backwardness in society where
you're right I mean people went when
they when they do Haram they don't care
about what people think
and then when they want to do Hallel
they want all these permissions and all
that I think a lot of times it's a it's
a it could be many things right I don't
want to sit there and limit it to one or
two things but but if I had to choose
and what I've seen a lot of times is
there's a form of manipulation that
people use where when they when they're
doing something hello they find all
these excuses that they need all these
permissions and all these restrictions
and reasons and so it forces them to oh
wow you know I tried to do something
good it didn't work out and now they
become a victim of circumstance and they
use a circumstance as are being
responsible instead of done being
responsible so there's this lack of
responsibility and accountability that
we are doing in our life we're forcing
other people and this is why I used to
be very active as a mental I'm not as
active anymore because I found a lot of
the mentees that I was mentoring made me
responsible for their decisions you know
after I was like what do you want to do
and they'll do a decision and if it
doesn't work out or not the way they
want to they'll blame me and so a lot of
times is
lame society yeah talk about this prime
I mean it's a reality that now it's a
sad reality but we're keeping it real
here and that say a woman she spent her
whole life chasing a career and now
she's you know twenty or twenty thirty
and above and you see this live now
you're there at the sessions that men
they overlook this one why because they
say she's pastor but what does that mean
yeah I think I think what happens is
there's just fear and bull fans you know
on the guys and there's that commitment
and then I'm a female and they're like
okay well you know they're
second-guessing themselves so I think
that I think that we I think both sides
men and women what happens is men will
manipulate the situation by not
committing or finding reasons not to
commit and then woman where you find
reasons well what this guy is not good
enough for or don't find the reason
where he's not religious enough or he's
not a scholar or [ __ ] which very few of
the men are and and or saying well I
need to finish my degree because what if
it doesn't work out so they don't come
in so there's a manipulation going on on
both ends or they're playing a game
saying it's your fault but really
they're not taking accountability for
their decisions and commitments or even
choosing to you know complete half their
Dean yeah so what happens now like for
the for for the the woman we talked
about the men who she's just you know
parents are also pushed education
education education education at the end
of the day now she's finished all her
education and we're seeing this not she
can't get married yeah what was
happening a lot of times and a lot of
the woman don't realize this is when new
men are ready to get married let's just
say that 32 years old right and they're
ready to get married a lot of them men
realistically speaking they're looking
for females who are ready to get married
at 25 26 or so far so a lot of these
other females who might have taken
longer to get the education and want to
be a doctor whatever the case is they're
hitting their mid 30s or even late 20s
mid 30s early thirties and so there's a
lot more woman who or the woman who want
to get married they're much younger
during college whatever and they're
trying to get married and I've seen this
like recently one of the
Matrimonial on-site locations where
there was a girl that came in she was
ready to get married she was second
third year in college she is 20 years
old and they were like at least 10 men
waiting in line to talk to her and then
I saw a lot of these older females who
finished their degree there in their
career they're very successful in the
world leave done your point of view and
they have like no guy talking to him and
and I think that that's you know like
this young 20 year old girl what she was
emotionally mature enough to realize
look you know I'm gonna finish my degree
but I want to find somebody to and it's
gonna take time and so she was able to
get engaged as far as I know now she's
on the you know stage of getting married
and then these other females from what
I've seen many of them still haven't
been able to find a person if they do
it's somebody like much senior numb or
somebody from a different country yeah
we're seeing it's really growing in the
UK this this problem is it's growing
it's not decreasing where the woman has
chased her career and there's nothing
wrong obviously the Islamic urges that
but at the same time I mean half our
Deen is marriage so now this dilemma
happens the the woman can't they say and
I know this is very sensitive for some
people but the reality on the ground is
something that we need to know but Islam
alters we see in the UK that now these
women are they're actually requesting
they're they want the shakes the the the
leaders to advocate for them to call out
these other brothers because this is
actually a mercy for the women that now
these the only one who's gonna step up
are the real men the one who are already
you know have a family okay to take on
another responsibility otherwise to
protect these women from from you know
falling into zina and and and other
things that now that can destroy their
Deen
yeah I mean I see it happening a lot I
mean a couple quick things I want to say
about that number one I know in America
you're only allowed to marry one wife
and I'm married to one wife I'm happily
married you know I'm not looking at I'm
not considering for myself personally to
marry more than one wife I have but I
think in certain situations that
possibly like in the UK where there's a
lot more females or even certain parts
of America there's a lot more females
than men I can see as long as it's not
going against the local law that there's
a way to
to kind of bridge the gap I mean even
when non-muslims they say in New York
there's 1 million more females than men
you know more woman than men and so I
think that it's becoming a huge epidemic
with that and also many men who are who
are interested in only men almost idols
and all that stuff there's less men
available for these woman who are
available age group to get married so I
think there's an epidemic all over
there's many ways to look at options to
resolve this and that can be one yes
yeah we know it's an Islam is clear you
know Christianity is clear Judaism
husband and wife man and woman come
together to raise a healthy family and
this alternative actually have you heard
of this and it's an interesting that you
have the not yet Muslims out there who
have actually taken this there's have
you heard of this show Sister Wives
Sister Wives we go to a clip real quick
let the people know that we're talking
about you're about to be a man who has
four wives
and they'll all say they're one big
happy family next here tonight the news
about polygamy on whether a man can live
with more than one wife to be clear it's
absolutely illegal in this country to
have a marriage license with more than
one person at one time but a big court
decision coming out of Utah seems to say
it's okay if you just skip the official
piece of paper what does it mean for
these girls to be your girlfriend living
this lifestyle
we know them as reality TV stars on the
hit show Sister Wives I wouldn't want
anything else
but now Hollywood's most famous
polygamists have taken on a new unlikely
role as legal Crusaders embroiled in a
courtroom fight over the fate of
polygamy are you prepared to take this
all the way to the Supreme Court if you
have to absolutely it is an epic battle
Kody Brown and all those wives meri
Janelle Robyn and Christine against the
state of Utah we're moving so we can
stay a family we're gonna move in three
days after the family flaunted their
plural lifestyle on TV authorities went
after them and the Browns fled Utah for
Nevada it's
chemistry this group then they suit
claiming a First Amendment right to live
how they want to live it was really an
issue of freedom of expression freedom
of love anybody should be able to
organize their family according to how
they choose and they want the first
American polygamy ruling in more than
130 years
a federal judge siding with them in
December declaring a key part of Utah's
polygamy law unconstitutional Kody Brown
can openly live with his wives just as
long as there is only one marriage
license and kody is only legally married
to meri Brown the others are his
spiritual wives it's nice though to not
have the word felon attached to our name
thousands of people living plural
marriage in Utah now are are free so in
this clip you saw that now they actually
went to the court and actually won the
case well they've been public about
their lifestyle for some time they've
always worried that Joe could face
arrest under the state's anti polygamy
laws but in December that became less
likely a federal judge ruled that a law
banning unlawful cohabitation goes
against the right to freedom of religion
while the main branch of the Mormon
faith banned polygamy in the 1890s the
Duggars are members of one of the
offshoots that continued the practice as
long as it's adults freely choosing what
they want then I I don't feel like it
would be my place to tell somebody else
you can't choose to love who you love I
think you're gonna start seeing more
people like us become more public well
I've had many of our friends and
relatives that have said you know I
could just tell people at work Who I am
now
regarding this and I got this this
gentleman he's got four four families
that he's taken care of so this is
actually a mercy this is twenty
eight-year-old Isaiah and his two wives
28 year-old Marlene and 20 year-old
Becca so you two have been married for
how long 10 years 10 years and
YouTube and that's three of me married
for about a year and half thank you for
pointing that out
Marlene and Isaiah married young
both were only 18 but committed to
living in a plural marriage
if Isaiah would have told me that he
didn't want this before we got married I
wouldn't have married him vice versa
after eight years of living in monogamy
they were joined by his second wife
Becca so what happened with you one day
I was in church and I was sitting with
my sister Sharon and I saw him walk
through the door not a felon just come
on bromine um I turned to Sharon and I
said yeah that's that's who I felt like
I belonged to at 19
Becca married Isaiah and Marlene as I
watched the three of them laughing
joking and making sushi they make it
look so easy they could be the poster
family for polygamy and I have to wonder
did they always get along this well yeah
kind of mess with my head a little bit I
mean we're so different you know I mean
I'm tall she's short I'm brunette would
you characterize it as kind of a little
envy or jealousy initially yeah
yeah I think there's absolutely
jealousies to work through I think it's
a normal human emotion you know I you
know we ask people what what other
solution do you have can't look at it
from sharing your man aspect you have to
look at it like joining the family like
her kids are my kids and if I couldn't
have kids I would still have kids if he
was gone I wouldn't be alone I would
have her you know and so it's a lot more
than just being jealous over your men
mm-hmm
because that's nothing compared to what
you have for this growing epidemic if if
it is for me and if I'm willing to do
that I feel like I have every right
to watch over protectors as far as just
our interaction the kids have all been
raised all together as a family and they
just interact really well together their
siblings and they love each other and it
I don't know it just works really well
this young family has redefined what a
happy marriage can look like I really do
love her she treats me like a wife you
know she wants the same for me but she
wants for herself and I don't know what
she's huge blessing you talk about 1
million extra here and and and this we
got a do not maybe another show that
people would like to see us to talk more
about this so here we guess I'm coming
back from an event a few months ago and
my driver is from Pakistan and which a
seeing you know how taxi drivers like to
chat he's telling me about his first
wife who just came over from Pakistan
she's really young she's got two
toddlers and I'm empathizing a lot I'm
telling him the story about you know she
just needs to integrate she used to get
more friends and Chad and so we get on
very very well the very end of the
journey so get back to my house in
Brooklyn he says would you like to be my
second wife and so I never ever thought
about polygamy until that actual moment
and the trouble is he was so incredibly
good-looking that I actually considered
it at the end of the day now we're
almost out of time
what else have you seen that you think
is something that is relevant now that
we can people can benefit from your
experience if you pray five times a day
and you wear a hijab and then you think
that's important and then you marry a
man that doesn't want you to wear a
hijab and once you just stay home and to
not do anything you have to marry
someone that's will fin you're a
religious level if you pray five times a
day marry someone that prays five times
a day and or willing to learn to pray
five times a day thank you very much for
being with us on Leguizamo and there you
have it from someone on the ground at
the meet and greets coordinator for
half-hour Dean here in Chicago and when
you have a connection with the one who
created you your maker the one who
sustains you takes care of you want to
please him half your Dean is completed
so you didn't get permission now to go
ahead
do the haram to do the things I just
please into the crater now when you want
to do some halau take the necessary
steps and go ahead and achieve it and
don't let anyone stand in your way as
long as you're doing the right taking
the right course of action and you're
doing it to please your Creator and this
is the way that you please your Creator
is completing half of your Deen stay
away from the dating of your coworker at
work and your monkeying around messing
around and at the end of the day you're
having fun in the wrong way but now when
it comes to protecting your chastity or
Dean what you're throwing everything all
these morals and all the teachings out
of the window don't let that happen to
you
don't get tripped and trap by the pimp
Shaitaan the biggest pimp look to do it
the right way and hopefully you got the
benefit from someone on the ground and
inshallah you tune in every week here to
the Dean show subscribe if you haven't
already we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you